Guten Abend. Mein Name ist Alie. Ich bin der Suchtständige als heute für Sie.
Guten Abend Herr Doktor.
Zuerst, wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Victoria Engel.
Also Victoria Engel.
Das ist eine herrliche Name, ne?
Victoria heißt der Sieg, ja.
Nein, Sie.
Ein schöner Name.
Victoria, ja, genau.
Also ein herrlicher Name bedeutet ein schöner Name.
Victoria, ja.
Das ist ein, nicht ein herrlicher, sondern, du wolltest glaube ich männlicher Name sagen.
Männlicher, ja.
Ja, jetzt verstehe ich. Nein, das ist ein weiblicher Name.
Weiblicher Name, genau. Victor ist deine männliche Name, ne?
Victor ist männlich, genau. Das ist richtig.
Da haben Sie Recht.
Also ich möchte sicher zurückgehen und Ihre Nachname wuchstabieren.
Emily, Envy, Neutrol, Gustau, Evy, Emily und Elvylutvik.
Engel, Engel wie die Engel.
Danke. Frau Engel, wie alt sind Sie dann?
Ich bin 53 Jahre alt.
Und wann wurden Sie geboren?
Mein Geburtstatus ist der 13. Januar 1970.
Okay. Wie groß sind Sie?
1,78 m.
Und wie viel Wegen Sie so seid?
Oh je, da fragen Sie mich aber Sachen.
Ich muss überlegen, ich denke mal so 85 kg.
Danke für die Informationen.
Frau Engel, was kann ich für so tun?
Ach, Doktor, ich habe seit einigen Tagen so ein komisches Gefühl im Kopf.
Ich habe so starke Kopfschmerzen im Hinterkopfbereich.
Und seit heute ist mir auch etwas übel, misswindlich.
Ich fühle mich im Gesamt nicht sehr wohl.
Und alles ist sehr komisch ein bisschen.
Okay.
Frau Engel, hätten Sie ähnliche Beschwerden vorher?
Oder das ist für Sie neu?
Ne, das ist das erste Mal eigentlich.
Es macht mir jetzt auch ein bisschen Angst.
Weil ich heute auch so ein bisschen Kribbeln im Arm hatte.
Und so einen ganz leichten Druck auf der Brust.
Okay.
Frau Engel, ist Ihnen irgendwelche Medikamente allegim bekannt?
Allegien? Nein, habe ich nicht.
Nein, allegien habe ich nicht.
Ist mir jetzt nicht bekannt bisher.
Okay. Wann haben Sie letztes Mal etwas gegessen?
Also, jetzt haben wir ungefähr 20 Uhr, also vor vier, fünf Stunden,
um hier zum Abendessen.
Okay.
Also, Frau Engel, ich wurde diese Gespräche pauseieren und Ihre Vitalwerte,
ich meine Lebenwerte überprüfen.
Was für Werte?
Lebenwerte, ja.
Das ist meine Ehre, Blutdruck, als Blut, Sauerstoffstätigung.
Die Vitalwerte.
Ja, so.
Lieber, Lebenwerte, kenne ich nicht, aber Vitalwerte, ja.
Vitalwerte?
Lebenwerte geht nicht, okay.
Vitalwerte, ja.
Okay.
Oder Vitalparameter, kann man auch sagen.
Ja, okay.
Ein Blutdruck von 210 zu 110, Puls 95.
Entschuldigung, 210.
210 zu 110, Millimeter HG der Blutdruck, Puls 95,
Sauerstoffstätigung 96.
Ja, Atemfreikanzis nicht so wichtig.
Atemfreikanzis normal, 14.
16, okay.
Ja, Frau Engel, wir haben Ihre Blutdruck etwas hochgefunden.
Ich möchte dagegen etwas tun.
Das wäre sehr schön, ja.
Ich möchte Ihnen eine Spray Ihrer Untersunge spressen.
Ja, Prühen.
Wie bitte?
Sprühen.
Ja, ich spreche Sprühen, ja.
Okay, gegen was ist das?
Ist das für den Blutdruck oder was ist das, Herr Doktor?
Wahrscheinlich, es ist so früher, ja, etwas zu sagen.
Nein, ich meine, dieses Spray, das Sie mir geben wollen.
Ja, das ist gegen diese Blutdruck, ja.
Wir haben Ihre Blutdruck etwas hoch festgestellt, ja.
Okay, okay, alles klar.
Und dagegen haben wir diese Spray gesproche.
Okay, alles klar.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Können wir jetzt weiterführen?
Fühlen Sie sich gut?
Ja, das ist ein komisches Geschmack, Herr Doktor.
Ist das normal so im Mund?
Dieses Spray schmeckt komisch?
Ja, das ist ein bisschen vielleicht, aber kann es sein auch andere Bedeutung?
Okay.
Später sehen wir, woher kommt diese komische Geschmack, ja?
Okay, Frau Engel, Sie haben gesagt, dass sie Krippe gefühlt,
wo fühlen Sie denn genau diese Krippe gefühlt?
Also ich war hier an der Außenseite des linken Arms,
an meiner Hand hier auf der Außenseite.
Aber das war heute Morgen ganz kurz, Sie sind auch wieder weg.
Okay, haben Sie auch so seit Krippe gefühlt, oder ist das schon weg?
Das ist schon weg, ja.
Okay, haben Sie die andere Seite auch diese gefühlt, komische gefühlt?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Die Beine, die unteren Gleide, haben Sie auch so schön gefühlt?
Die unteren Glieder oder Beine, da habe ich jetzt nichts, da war keine Auffälligkeit.
Okay.
Haben Sie Kopfschmerzen?
Ja, deswegen bin ich ja gekommen, also seit drei Tagen.
Das ist immer schlimmer geworden, jetzt kam seit gestern auch noch ein Schwinde dazu.
Und ich habe mich etwas schwer getan beim Laufen.
Also sind Sie beschwerter und plötzlich auch getreten?
Kann ich nicht sagen, ich würde eher sagen, das hat sich langsam entwickelt.
Ich wundere mich, ich habe bisher immer einen niedrigen Blutdruck gehabt,
weil wenn der Haushatz das gemessen hat, war er so bei 120 zu 70 oder 110, 80.
Also einen hohen Blutdruck kenne ich eigentlich gar nicht, das wundert mich jetzt.
Das heißt bisher, bei Ihnen, keine Bluthochdruck festgestellt?
Nein, ich spiele regelmäßig beim Hausarzt,
gut, das ist jetzt auch ungefähr ein Jahr her, als ich das letzte Mal beim Hausarzt war.
Aber da war der Blutdruck immer in Ordnung.
Okay, gut, das ist gut.
Also Frau Engel, wie starten die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala von 0 bis 10?
Also welche Schmerzen meinen Sie?
Die Kopfschmerzen.
Haben Sie andere Schmerzen, außer Kopfschmerzen?
Ja gut, wie gesagt, heute Morgen war das mir auf der Brust ein bisschen komisch,
aber das ist auch weg, das war nur ganz kurz.
Die Kopfschmerzen sind jetzt auch nach dem Spree ein bisschen besser geworden.
Ich würde sagen, maximal war es so bei 4 oder 5 Ihrer Skala.
Okay, also Frau Engel, haben Sie auch so seit Atemnot oder Engelgefühl im Brustbereich?
Also Atemnot habe ich jetzt nicht.
Allgemein komisches Gefühl, so innere Unruhe, manchmal so rote Backen.
Okay.
Ich werde auch eine Eke geschrieben, gleichzeitig, wir können gleichzeitig diese Gespräche führen, ja?
Okay, ja, lieben gern, ja, sehr gut.
Und, könnten Sie mir sagen, sind die Schmerzen, also die Schmerzen drückend, ich meine die Kopfschmerzen, ja?
Ja, das ist mehr so im Hinterkopf, und das ist so ein bisschen, ich würde sagen, drückende Schmerzen, ja?
Sehr unangenehm.
Ja, und gibt es etwas, diese Schmerzen verstärkert oder lindert?
Kann ich nicht sagen, die sind eigentlich immer da gewesen, jetzt nein.
Keine Auslöser haben Sie bemerkt, ne, diese Schmerzen?
Nein, nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie Übelkeit, Erbrüche oder Durchbrüche?
Nein, das hat ich ja gesagt, dass ich solche Stimme habe.
Wir haben Übel, haben Sie schon...
Gestern auch Übelkeit haben, aber Erbrochen habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Ein Durchwahl?
Nein, nein, habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang oder beim Wasserlassen?
Nein, das war bisher immer sehr gut, da hatte ich keine Sorgen.
hat sich Gehörig in der Lesterzeit verändert. Ich meine ab oder so genommen haben Sie?
Nein, also da habe ich bisher keine Probleme, immer relativ gleich geblieben.
Meine Kleidergröße sind gleich. Da hat sich an dem Gewicht glaube ich nicht viel geändert.
Okay, haben Sie Fieber oder Schütterfrost nach Schweiß? Nein, nein.
Okay, wie ist Ihre Schlaf? Können Sie in der Nacht gut schlafen?
Ja, also da habe ich eigentlich keine Probleme. Ich kann relativ gut einschlafen.
Aber jetzt in den letzten Tagen bin ich in der Nacht öfters wach geworden,
weil ich so eine Unruhe hatte, so eine innere komische Unruhe, auch ein bisschen Kopfschmerzen.
Okay. Das war aber jetzt in den letzten zwei, drei Tagen.
Ähm, höstern Sie Frau Engel?
Wo ist denn nein, habe ich nicht. Nein, okay.
Leiden Sie unter irgendwelche chronischen Erkrankungen?
Ich meine, der Bullitochtdruck, also Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie keine Bullitochtdruck, ja?
Ja, aber ich bin eigentlich nichts bekannt. Ich nehme keine Medikamente ein.
Ich bin ja weich und eigentlich relativ gesund.
Also, wichtige Erkrankungen oder chronische Erkrankungen, ja?
Nein, das sind Sie nicht bekannt.
Wurden Sie schon mal operiert? Einmal?
Vielleicht? Nein.
Okay. Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie keine Allegge haben.
Können Sie alles, haben Sie irgendwelche Unerträglichkeit gegen Essen
oder Unverträglichkeit?
Unverträglichkeit. Nein, habe ich nicht. Nein, ist nicht bekannt.
Okay. Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit Ausland gewesen oder eine Reise?
Ja, wir waren im letzten Sommer mal in Griechenland, circa zehn Tage.
Vor zehn Tagen.
In Griechenland.
Wann war das vor zehn Tagen, haben Sie gesagt?
Nein, im letzten Sommer.
Im nöster Sommer, okay.
Okay.
Frau Engel, sind Sie sehr vollständig geimpft?
Ja, also bevor wir in den Urlaub gefahren sind, hat mein Hausarzt die Impfungen
nochmal überprüft, er meinte, die sind alle komplett.
Auch gegen Corona auch?
Ja, ja, da bin ich schon dreimal geimpft.
Okay.
Treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport, Frau Engel?
Eigentlich nicht, bin ich nicht so sportlich, leider.
Okay.
Frau Engel, ich möchte über Ihre Familiale Anamnise erheben.
Das heißt, Ihre Mutter und Vater, sind Ihre Eltern am Leben?
Ja, sie leben noch, sie sind auch gesund.
Okay.
Was versteht man?
Das heißt, Sie haben keine, leiden Sie keine unter irgendwelche chronischen
Krankungen oder wichtige Krankungen?
Also, Sie sind natürlich schon alt, ja.
Mein Vater ist vierundachtzig, meine Mutter ist 18, 70 Jahre alt.
Und wir haben natürlich schon so ein paar Krankungen,
aber den geht es eigentlich ganz gut.
Okay.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe noch einen Bruder.
Ja, ist der gesund?
Ja, ja, ist jünger als ich, der hat auch bisher zumindest keine
Erkrankungen.
Okay.
Also, ich nehme an, dass Ihre Mutter und Vater keine
wichtige Erkrankungen leidet.
Nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Okay, das ist schön.
Frau Engel, was machen Sie als beruflich?
Ich bin Lehrerin.
Okay.
Also, Sie sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe zwei Kinder.
Einen Sohn und eine Tochter.
Okay.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, glücklicherweise.
Also, die sind beide jetzt an der Universität und studieren
und sind eigentlich gesund.
Okay.
Leben Sie mit Ihrem Ehemann zusammen?
Ja, ja.
Okay.
Sind Sie sofrieden beim Arbeit?
Ja, mein Beruf macht mir Spaß.
Ich bin gerne bei der Arbeit und da habe ich auch keine Probleme.
Das gefällt mir sehr gut, meine Arbeit.
Okay.
Das ist gut.
Frau Engel, rauchen Sie?
Bitte?
Rauchen Sie?
Rauchen, nein.
Okay, haben Sie schon mal geraucht?
Nein, ansichtlich nicht.
Okay, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, sehr selten.
Wie meinen Sie?
Also, vielleicht einmal im Monat oder so, aber ich bin sonst nicht.
Okay, nur einmal.
Wenig.
Also, bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich.
Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie Kontakt damit, Dräger?
Das bedrohen Sie?
Okay.
So, Frau Engel, wie ist Ihre Periode?
Haben Sie Periode oder sind Sie so seit dem Wechseljahr?
Oder durch Wechseljahren?
Ich bin in der Menopause, das stimmt.
Seit drei Jahren schon.
Aber ich habe jetzt keine so großen Symptome oder Schwierigkeiten.
Okay, besuchen Sie Ihre Frau aus regelmäßig?
Ja, ich gehe einmal im Jahr, versuche schon beim Gynäkologen,
die Untersuchungen zu machen.
Das ist gut, ja.
Das machen Sie gut.
So, Frau Engel, ich möchte kurz zusammenfassen.
Also, seit einigen Tagen haben Sie Kopfschmerzen und komische Gefühle,
Übelkeit, ja, das ist für Sie erst einmal.
Und Sie haben gestern Linken am Krippegefühl gefühlt.
Und diese komische Gefühle sind zunehmende,
ja, dass alle die Beschwerden langsam auch getreten.
Und die Schmerzenintensität ist 4, 5, auch von Szenzekala, ja.
Sie fühlen diese Schmerzendruckende, ja.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen an nicht?
Nein, vielen Dank.
Sie haben sich sehr bemüht.
Und ich fühle mich ja schon besser nach dem Spree.
Hier der Blutdruck, der ist ja jetzt auch runter auf 170 zu 90.
Und die Kopfschmerzen sind jetzt auch ein bisschen besser geworden.
Okay.
Gut.
Also, jetzt machen wir es.
Was meinen Sie, Herr Doktor, was das jetzt ist?
Ja, ich denke, das ist eine sogenannte transistorische,
schämische Attac in Ihrem Kopf, ja.
Aufgrund dieser erhöhten Blutdruck, ja.
Aber wir müssen sicher so gehen.
Und wir müssen sicher gehen und Ihre körperliche Untersuchung
und Blutabliemen in einer operative Diagnostik durchführen, ja.
Okay, gut.
Ich habe es nicht verstanden, was diese transistorische Dinge da heißen.
Aber ich bedrohe Ihnen, ich denke, Sie möchten ja noch einige Untersuchungen machen.
Muss ich hier bleiben oder kann ich heute wieder nach Hause?
Also, Sie müssen hier bleiben, bei uns bleiben, ja.
Hier mit der Spiegel, Ihnen beobachten.
Okay.
Ja, schauen Sie mal, ich würde am liebsten nach Hause gehen,
aber Sie wollen wahrscheinlich jetzt noch mit Ihrem Oberarzt sprechen.
Ja, genau.
Wir machen sowas.
Guten Tag.
Mein...
Oberarzt?
Ja.
Meine Kollegen ist neue,
und deswegen eine Tier-Siebrichter.
Dann, dann, dann, dann, ich würde mich beantworten.
Okay, alles klar.
Hab'n Kollegen, oder Kollegen, frag'n.
Alle, Sie ist hierr-, hierr-gier, nicht inneremmedes,
oder Kardiologe, und deswegen erstmal Diagnose.
Sehr gut, aber ich schau' euch, mit dem Blutrück umgehen können.
Ja, alles klar.
Aber immer noch.
Wenn Sie eine Tier denken,
müssen Sie diese Frage zähstürm,
zähstürm, o-stürm, sprachstürm, lehmung, lehmung und syncope.
Also die neurologischen Symptome muss man natürlich abfragen
und auf dem Körper den Patienten neurologisch untersuchen.
Aber das macht der Kollege noch diese Untersuchungen.
Okay.
Können wir anfangen, Arsanski-Schicklö?
Emil, schau' es mal!
Ja.
Ein Moment.
Nuozea.
Ich desionale.
Ja
Guten Abend.
Sie hatten so große Zeit für mich.
Ah, unser Doktor Ani, der eifige Doktor.
Guten Abend, ja natürlich.
Ich möchte neuem Passier-
Prost stellen.
Also, Frau
Victoria Engel
ist eine
53-jährige Patientin
die sich heute Morgen
bei uns aufgrund
seit
einige Tagen
hinter Hauptschmerzen
sowie neu sehr
vorgestellt
hat.
Die Patientin
vorgestellt hat.
Ja, vorgestellt hat.
Die Patientin berichtet,
dass die Schmerzen
langsam aufgetreten
sein und im Laufe
der Zeit
für Schlimmer hätten.
Die Schmerzen
seien auf einer Schmerzskala
4-5 Einzuordnungen
seien
und
sie seien
drückend
also
und
die
vegetative Anamnese
ist unauffällig bis auf
äh
also nein
außerdem die Patientin berichtet
dass sie
äh
Hiphäuste sie
im linken Arm
und
geschmeckt
äh
habe
diese komische Geschmack hat sie nach dem Spree
vielleicht wegen
die Spree ja
äh
nicht gehabt, nein, okay
also vielleicht ich habe
vergessen, am Anfang haben sie komische
oder sehr störigen
Sprachstörungen
Nein, hat sie nicht gehabt
ja
und äh die
die
vegetative Anamnese
ist unauffällig bis auf
äh neuseher
äh
und insomnia
Kopfschmerz hat sie auch gehabt
Kopfschmerz sind
ja, am Anfang habe ich das eventuell
die inter Kopfschmerz sind
okay
unsere Hauptbeschwerden
äh an
Vorerkrankungen gibt
keine
beim Patienten
äh
habe leider keine
Vorerkrankungen
äh
und äh
nie mehr ja keine Medikamente ein
ihr nehmt keine Medikamente ein
sie nehmen
sie nehmen keine Medikamente ein
und äh
sie wurden nie operiert
äh
sie sei seit 3 Jahren
Wechseljahr
in den Wechseljahren
ja, sie besuche regelmäßig
äh ihre
Frauenarzt
äh bei die Patienten
äh
keine Allergien bekannt
bei der Patientin
ist keine Allergie bekannt
bei die Patientin
sei keine Allergien bekannt
okay
Konjunktive 1 möchte ich machen
okay, sei keine Allergien bekannt, ihr wollt
und äh
sie sei vollständig
geirrt
äh auch gegen Corona 3-mal
äh
sie
sei
äh
letzte Sommer
im Ausland gewesen
aber das spielt keine Rolle
so seit für uns
äh
sie waren im Gerischenland
ja, eine Gerischenland, ja
hat sie hier in Europa
ja, in Europa, ja
äh sie treibe
keine Sport
äh
als Familienanalyse
gibt keine äh
Besonderes
seine ihre Mutter
und Vater am Leben
und äh
sie seien gesund
wir haben
eine gesunde Bruder
äh kleine Alzi
junge Alzi
junge Alzi, ja
äh
und äh sie sei
äh Lehrerin
aus Beruf und äh
sie sei zufrieden
äh
äh sie sei
äh verheiratet
habe zwei gesunde
äh Kinder, eine
einen Sohn, eine Tochter
äh äh
sie sei nicht raucherin
äh
nehme selten
äh Trinke, nehme
Trinke, selten Alkohol
und äh
keine Kontakte mit
mit dem Drogen
äh
die anamnistischen Angaben
deuten am ehesten
auf
äh transistorische
ist die Monsieur Attac
äh
als differential Diagnose
kommen äh
Apopleks
äh hier
und tomorrow
äh meningitis
oh okay
äh
äh also
äh in Betracht
äh
äh um
Verdacht auf
um äh den Verdacht
auf äh
transistorische
ist chemische Attac
äh äh
äh
äh die
die Differenziat Diagnose
auszuschließen
äh wird äh
äh eine
äh körperliche Untersuchung
äh um
äh
Und als körperliche Untersuchung würde ich die Patienten
zur Aspektion durchführen und eine abnormale Bewegung in dem Gleiden beobachten
oder eine Pleschie beobachten.
Es könnte eine Hörner-Sendrum beim Aspektion feststellen.
Beim neurologischen Untersuchung kann man die Papi, die Hypostasee,
Parästhesie und pathologische Reflexen untersuchen.
Okay, alles klar. Machen wir jetzt mal einen Punkt.
Ich denke, das war nicht schlecht, aber es ist zu weit gedacht.
Immer ganz einfach denken, es gibt ein Sprichwort.
Was viel ist viel, was wenig ist, ist wenig.
Die Patientin kommt, hat Kopflärmung über Geheimnis,
sie haben den Blutdruck gemessen, der war bei 210 zu 110.
Was hat die Patientin am Anfang jetzt?
Ganz einfach. Welche Diagnose ist das?
Hypertensiv.
Wir nennen mal so eine Blutdruck, die wahnsinnig hoch ist.
Können die Kollegen helfen?
Wie heißt ein sehr hoch entgleister Blutdruck?
Eine hypertensive.
Eine Blutdruck entgleistert.
Hypertensive Attacke oder eine hypertensive Krise.
Die Patientin hat einen sehr hohen Blutdruck.
Ganz einfach formuliert.
Ich stimme nicht ganz zu, dass es eine Tier ist.
Eine Tier ist es nicht oder noch nicht.
Das ist nur Kopfschmerzen und Üblichkeit.
Dieses Kribbeln, das war jetzt ein kleiner Trick,
um sie ein bisschen zu verärgern.
Das war schnell wieder weg.
Das kann sein, dass sie auch Verspannungen hat durch die Kopfschmerzen.
Deswegen, die Hauptdiagnose hier ist,
eine hypertensive Entgleisung oder eine hypertensive Krise.
Weil sie hat vorher keinen hohen Blutdruck,
eine Medikamente, es ist langsam aufgekommen.
Sie hat Kopfschmerzen, das geht über einige Tage.
Übelkeit, Schwindel.
Das sind Symptome eines hohen Blutdrucks.
Das ist noch keine Tier.
Wie der Kollege vorhin schon gesagt hat,
bei den Tier brauchen wir schon mehr neurologische Symptome.
Das heißt, richtige Armschwäche
oder Sprachstörung, also eine Aphasie
oder richtige Lebungen.
Tier heißt nur, dass diese neurologischen Symptome
nach einer kurzen Zeit wieder weggehen.
Nach einer halben Stunde, nach einer Stunde.
Das kann auch eine richtige Hemiplegie sein.
Wenn sie wieder weggehen, dann ist es auch wieder eine Tier.
Der Auslöse ist meistens auch ein hohen Blutdruck.
Aber hier hat die Patientin gesagt,
sie hat aus einem ganz leichtes Kribbel keine See- und Sprechstörung.
Und nachher würde ich die Diagnose stellen,
eine hypertensive Krise oder eine hypertensive Entgleisung.
Differenzial diagnostisch würde ich sagen,
Tier, Apoplex, Hirntumor, Menigitis, alles gut.
Oder auch etwas ganz Einfaches.
Ein grippaler Infekt, zum Beispiel,
was wir jetzt im Moment sehr viel haben, macht auch die gleiche Symptome.
Kopfschmerzen, Unwohlsein, Übelkeit, Schwäche,
alle Glieder tun weh, Nacken, Rückenn, Schulter.
Auch ein grippaler Infekt kann solche Symptome machen.
Eine Covid-Infektion kann solche Symptome machen.
Als Differenzialdiagnose.
Ansonsten war das sehr gut.
An amnesie, Untersuchung, Kontrolle, unterbrechen,
erst mal die Vitalparameter.
Ein Lebenparameter im Deutsch gibt es nicht.
Leben, ja.
Vital heißt Leben, aber diesen Begriff gibt es nicht.
Weiß ich, die kennen dieser Vitalparameter nicht.
Doch, Vitalparameter ist ein deutsches Wort, kann man machen.
Ömön, wenn wir als Alsars-Springen
hinter dem Kopf oder den Okspitalbereich am besten ist?
Kann man beide sagen.
Hinter Kopfschmerzen ist auch gut.
Oder Schmerzen mit Hauptschwertpunkt am Hinterkopf, kann man sagen.
Oder auch Okspital, Kopfschmerzen, kann man sagen.
Kopfschmerzen, das ist Sefalgi.
Sefalgi ist ein bülinischer Begriff, natürlich.
Alici hat gesagt, Hipostesi, nicht Hipostesi.
Hip-Estesi heißt es.
Nein, Parestesi.
Parestesi, ja.
Und Weißenjahr, umgangssprache, Klimakterium, oder Menopause.
Menopause oder Klimakterium, genau.
Sehr gut.
Aber wann ist die Prüfung, Herr Dr. Alici?
Wahrscheinlich am Ende dieses Monats.
Haben Sie noch keinen Termin?
Nein, ich warte den Jobcenter übernehmen, diese Prüfung geboren.
Das kostet 650.
Ah, okay.
Wenn ich möchte, dann bekomme ich eine Termin.
Ohne eine Termin.